[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
dans votre 7,8 week-end nous allons
parler actualités mais aussi loisirs
voici les titres de ce vendredi 29
janvier l'actualité c'est la déclaration
de candidature pour la présidence de la
région ile-de-france d'audrey pulvar
adjointe de la maire de paris anne
hidalgo elle se lance dans la campagne à
la tête d'une liste de gauche
l'officialisation de sa candidature nous
en parlerons avec dina bas diop chef de
file du parti socialiste dans les
yvelines
ce sera notre invité nous vous
proposerons aussi les idées sorties et
loisirs de signes agathe son goût avec
du cinéma ou encore des illuminations au
zoo de thoiry
enfin comme chaque semaine vincent
couronne créateur du site internet les
surligneurs décrypte les déclarations
des personnalités publiques et
politiques
aujourd'hui il décrypte les propos de
nicolas dupont aignan chef de file du
parti souverainiste sur
l'hydrochlorothiazide est aussi le
résumé de l'actualité de la semaine
[Musique]
l'actualité c'est la candidature à la
présidence du conseil régional
d'ile-de-france d'audrey pulvar élu
depuis six mois au conseil municipal de
paris est adjointe de la maire
socialiste anne hidalgo élections
régionales qui devrait se dérouler en
juin 2021
si la crise sanitaire le permet audrey
pulvar l'a annoncé dans les colonnes de
nos confrères du parisien
elle sera donc à la tête d'une liste de
gauche qui rassemblera le parti
socialiste le parti radical de gauche
place publique et allons enfants pour
réagir à cette annonce 10 naba diop
bonsoir vous êtes chef de file du parti
socialiste dans les yvelines adjointe au
maire des mureaux et vous serez tête de
liste pour le département sur la liste
devrait pulvar pour ces élections alors
juste avant de parler de cette
candidature
audrey pulvar était ce matin dans les
yvelines d'abord à verneuil sur seine
puis aux mureaux où elle a rencontré le
syndicat cfdt de l'usiné renault flins
on les couteaux micro d'astrid bergère
et célia gatting aux sommes organisés en
groupes de travail
on a 300 personnes qui qui travaillent
dans 22 22 groupes de travail sur des
sujets différents
nous avons produit des propositions des
idées et au bout d'un moment nous avons
considéré tous ensemble que le moment
était venu de passer l'étape supérieure
et d'y aller alors dit mama diop que
pensez-vous de la candidature d'audrey
pulvar seulement six mois après avoir
été élu en tant que conseillère
municipale adjointe à la mairie de paris
évidemment je me réjouis que la
candidature d audrey pulvar conseil
régional en présence du conseil régional
d'île de france
je pense qu'elle est une véritable
alternative à la candidature de valérie
pécresse parce que elle permet à la
gauche d'offrir un rassemblement et de
dépasser les querelles de chapelles qui
peuvent exister entre les différentes
formations politiques et je pense que
c'est important dans le temps qui a qui
est le nôtre d'avoir vu
nature de société civile qui peut
engranger autour d'elle des collectifs
citoyens des citoyen s'engager mais
aussi des des formations politiques
comme l'allier alors justement vous
parliez rassemblement est ce que comme
claude bartolone donc je le rappelle
candidat malheureux du parti socialiste
aux dernières élections régionales en
vous souhaitez faire liste commune avec
europe ecologie les verts eux élevé en
sachant que julien bayou évidemment
secrétaire nationale des verts a annoncé
sa candidature en tête de liste en août
dernier nous avions a justement contacté
l'équipe autour de audrey pulvar et du
transfèrement avait contacté cote chez
les verts en vue d'une alliance qui me
semblait la plus raisonnable de
l'ensemble de la gauche sachant qu'en
plus nous travaillons ensemble en imper
groupe au sein de l'opposition a de
valérie pécresse mais malheureusement
cette main tendue elle n'a pas été
saisie et julien bayou comme vous l'avez
rappelé a annoncé dès le mois d'août qui
partiraient seul sur ces élections
alors parlons un peu de votre programme
vous êtes je le rappelle tête de liste
dans les yvelines pour notre département
la mesure phare du programme d'audrey
pulvar et donc de votre liste sera la
gratuité des transports en ile-de-france
pourquoi parce que c'est une mesure qui
est à la fois écologique et sociale nous
sommes dans un temps où il faut
retrouver du pouvoir d'achat et pour que
les gens justement adopte des mobilités
qui sera plus adapté à notre lutte
justement contre le réchauffement
climatique
il faut les encourager avec une gratuité
des transports
mais elle n'ira de perk avec une un
renforcement et un investissement forts
pour justement donné des transports de
qualité à l'ensemble des franciliens
pensent que nous sommes parfaitement
conscients qu'il ya des endroits où nous
n'avons pas encore la possibilité
d'avoir et en sport digne de ce nom est
digne de la première région de france
et comment vous comptez financer cette
mesure ce que ça fait à ces débats cette
mesure en tout cas annoncés par audrey
pulvar
en fait il y avait il ya justement à
tous les coûts cachés
que nous estimons que nous estimons
pouvoir justement réinvestir sur cette
gratuité des transports
il y a aussi une contribution que nous
voudrions demander aux entreprises
notamment par exemple les entreprises
qui profitent à des de 2009 avec une
marge est très importante notamment sur
le e-commerce
nous allons aussi travailler sur tous et
à toutes les économies que nous allons
pouvoir faire si vous si vous arrêtez
justement le contrôle au niveau des
différentes des différents transports
s'est largement atteignable
bien sûr ce ne sera pas au lendemain de
notre élection mais c'est un but que
nous mois que nous nous assignons et une
pensons que c'est une véritable volonté
politique qui fait la différence entre
nous et la liste de m
et justement vous parlez de valérie
pécresse donc c'est l'actuelle
présidente de la région ile de france du
parti libre alors elle est pas encore
officiellement candidate aux élections
selon une enquête ifop de décembre 2020
elle serait tout de même en tête des
intentions de vote des franciliens
si jamais elle se présente est-ce que
vous vous sentez capable de l'affronter
bien sûr on ne s'y prépare et je pense
que le plus important ce n'est pas
seulement de l'affronter c'est d'être
capable de de proposer un projet
alternatif aux franciliens je pense que
c'est avant tout les citoyens qui nous
faut convaincre leur dire qu'ils ont une
véritable alternative avec nos
propositions avec les équipes que nous
incarnons et être au plus proche de la
préoccupation
par exemple nous nous sommes favorables
à rsa jeunes alors que valérie pécresse
se s'y opposer frontalement et pourtant
la crise que nous traversons montre bien
qu'elle se serait nécessaire quand nos
jeunes étudiants qui sont qui souffrent
énormément qui sont dans une grande
précarité pour la majorité d'entre
dernière question très rapidement est ce
que vous craignez que les élections
régionales et départementales soit
reporté une nouvelle fois et pourquoi
j'espère qu'elles ne seront pas parce
que on ne peut pas
consignes et notre démocratie et qu'il
est important que les franciliennes et
franciliens puissent se prononcer elle
notamment aussi pour les départementales
il suffit nous savons maintenant à tenir
des scrutins de manière à respecter les
gestes barrières pour qu'il n'y ait
aucun aucune prise de risque pour les
citoyens et il est important de laisser
ce temps démocratique s'excluent merci
dieynaba diop d'avoir été avec nous faut
du côté des autres candidats pour la
majorité présidentielle après le
renoncement du ministre de l'éducation
jean michel blanquer
jeudi 28 janvier ce sera le député
laurent saint martin qui conduira la
liste la république en marche
député du val de marne c'est aurore
bergé député lrm des yvelines et
président délégué du groupe la
république en marche à l'assemblée
nationale qui l'a annoncé ce vendredi
matin sur le plateau de nos confrères de
france info laurent saint martin
lui-même l'a également confirmé sur
twitter également le secrétaire général
du modem et député des yvelines jean
noël barrot a fait savoir qu'il aspirait
à être tête de liste pour la majorité
présidentielle il souhaite en tout cas
que son parti le modem soit en première
ligne pour les élections de juin
prochain
selon nos confrères des échos du côté
des verts je le rappelle julien bayou
secrétaire nationale d'europe écologie
les verts avait déjà officialisé sa
candidature en août dernier et enfin
l'actuelle présidente de l' île de
france valérie pécresse du parti libre
n'a pas encore fait savoir si elle se
représentait officiellement dans
l'actualité également la région ile de
france présentait mardi 29 janvier
l'avancement du plan d'urgence pour les
lycées franciliens votée en 2010 est un
plan qui a été revu suite à une nouvelle
étude réalisée en 2020 justin brasier
nous rappelle en quoi consiste ce plan
un plan pour lutter contre la vétusté
des lycées l'objectif de ce plan
d'urgence pour les lycées franciliens
construire de nouveaux lycées et rénover
les autres alors ce plan d'urgence avait
déjà été adoptée en 2010 est on le
rappelle par la région ile de france
il s'étend sur la période de 2017 à 2027
et prévoyez notamment
budget de 5 1 milliards d'euros parmi
lesquels 4,1 milliards alloués aux
investissements notamment dans les
équipements sportifs dans les
aménagements liés à l'accueil des
personnes en situation de handicap et
aussi dans la construction le milliard
d'euros restants est prévu pour la
maintenance et à dire dans les besoins
quotidiens
parmi les autres objectifs on trouve la
création aussi de 21 mille six cent
nouvelles places d'ici 2027
alors ce plan initié à le voter donc en
2017 a dû être révisée pourquoi et bien
tout simplement parce qu'ils se basent
sur une étude menée par l'institut paris
région en 2016
une étude qui a été mise à jour en 2020
qui montre une augmentation
supplémentaire de 65 mille cinq cents
lycéens public et d'ici 2030 par rapport
aux estimations de 2016 pour pallier le
problème le plan a été révisé et prévoit
la création de neuf mille places
supplémentaires dans les lycées
franciliens en plus de celles déjà
prévues
résultat 30 mille six cent nouvelles
places devraient être créés d'ici 2027
une opération qui nécessite donc un
budget supplémentaire qui s'élève à 900
millions d'euros portant ce plan
d'urgence révisé à 6 milliards d'euros
et le reste de l'actualité de la semaine
c'est astrid bergère qui nous la résume
en 78 secondes
[Musique]
lancement réussi de la fusée falcon line
avec à son bord le nano satellites
élaboré par le latmos de l'observatoire
versailles-saint-quentin duvet rescue
sat permettra d'observer le soleil et la
terre
19 cad coronavirus sur le campus hec à
jouy-en-josas ont été détectés une
campagne de dépistage massif a eu lieu
et les étudiants doivent rester
confinées dans attentes de leurs
résultats
plus de 70 enseignants étaient
rassemblés devant les locaux des
services départementaux de l'éducation
nationale à guyancourt
ils demandaient une amélioration de
leurs conditions de travail et des
revalorisations salariales renforcer les
sanctions en cas de maltraitance animale
depuis le 26 janvier
l'assemblée nationale examine un texte
de loi aurore bergé député de la 10e
circonscription des yvelines est
responsable du texte pour la majorité
deux mille deux cents dossiers en
attente au tribunal de versailles c'est
dix fois plus qu'à la fin 2019 un retard
pris à cause de la crise sanitaire la
parole était donnée à maryvonne
caillibotte procureur de la république
de versailles elle les plus belles
images de la semaine sont attribués à
louis burton le skipper originaire de
rambouillet malgré de nombreuses
péripéties pendant ces 80 jours en mer
il termine à la 3e place d'une deuxième
vendée globe
[Musique]
après cette semaine bien chargée et quoi
de mieux que de se détendre le week-end
comme chaque vendredi c'est lié à get on
go nous présente ses idées sorties et
loisirs
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
cette semaine nous allons parler de
cinéma depuis votre canapé
les rendez vous hors champ vous propose
des ciné-débats des films et conférences
en ligne en partenariat avec des lieux
culturels yvelinois justin brasier
bonjour bonjour vous allez peut-être
nous présenter à ce projet d'avoir
exactement donc c'est un projet mené par
quatre étudiantes elles sont en master
management des organisations culturelles
et artistiques à l'université de
versailles saint quentin en yvelines et
donc elle propose comme vous nous l'avez
dit à des projections donc des
ciné-débats et l'événement a lieu sur
trois jours donc ce sera les 3 4 et 5
février
alors quel est le programme donc il y
aura trois projections de films et
documentaires ils seront sur le thème de
la musique
et comme il s'agit de ciné débat et bien
ils seront suivis d'une discussion en
live d'une heure environ et les films et
documentaires eux vont aussi durée 1h
1h30 environ
et je vous propose d'écouter justin
coullier qui est responsable du projet
hors champ et puis elle va nous
expliquer les films retenus on a le
professeur de violon qui aborde la
pédagogie et qui intéressait beaucoup la
clé puisqu'ils ont beaucoup d'ateliers
d'apprentissage culturel
on a un père claude jeanne qui est en
lien avec la musique et le handicap et
qui intéressait la batterie parce que
ils ont des projets à venir avec des
associations des événements qui s'occupe
justement de projets entre la musique et
handicap et enfin on a le documentaire
french fries sur la musique électronique
et alors quel est l'objectif de ces
rendez vous pendant la période actuelle
c'est surtout mettre en valeur les
structures et les associations
culturelles dans les yvelines qui reste
active malgré cette crise sanitaire là
notamment il y aura trois partenaires
donc la clé à saint-germain-en-laye la
batterie de guyancourt et puis
l'association met assauts de
voisins-le-bretonneux et donc c'est leur
redonner de la visibilité pour leur
donner l'occasion de
de parler avec leurs abonnés leurs
adhérents ou aussi de se faire connaître
par exemple de nouveaux étudiants qui
n'ont pas pu découvrir ces structures en
arrivant par exemple pour faire leurs
études dans les yvelines
donc voilà alors donné une plateforme
pour discuter et pour parler de la
musique et de leur projet est passé ou
reporter qui arriveront quand il
pourrait offrir et comment fait-on pour
s'inscrire
alors pour participer il faut se rendre
sur le site de la 25e heure c'est en
fait une salle de cinéma virtuel qui
avait été créée face à la pandémie
justement de covile 19 avec notamment la
fermeture à des salles de cinéma est
donc là sur ce site vous pouvez réserver
vos places votre projection celle que
vous souhaitez et puis vous pouvez bien
sûr aussi passer par la page facebook
les rendez vous hors champ alors
attention les projections sont gratuites
mais le nombre de places est limité donc
je pense qu'il faudrait réserver l'avant
ce conseil merci beaucoup justin le
parcours d'illumination touahri lumière
sauvage au zoo de thoiry
initialement prévue le soir ouvre
finalement dès le matin à 7h30
exactement
nous recevons aujourd'hui à christelle
bercheny bonjour bonjour vous êtes la
directrice du zoo de thoiry
alors pourquoi ouvrir le parc à cette
heure-là eh bien on s'adapte on a monté
depuis quelques années un festival de
lumières sauvage qui est un festival un
parcours dans les jardins du château
avec un kilomètre 5 de lanternes
lumineuse qui raconte une histoire un
espoir c'est éric houle à cette année on
est dans les songes du comté d'un
explorateur qui a pu parcourir le monde
et veillées des animaux qui existait des
animaux un peu plus extraordinaires donc
voila et donc pour cela et pour qu on
offre le meilleur spectacle etc sans que
le la nuit soit le plus possible
présente donc on a décidé après les
moindres couvre-feu de 20h qui nous a
les taux bien en hiver puisque à 17
heures il faisait nuit et bien on s'est
adapté maintenant que le couvre-feu est
à 18 heures on a créé les veilles de
thoiry depuis la semaine dernière tous
les week-ends de 7h30 à 9h30
nos clients peuvent découvrir les
lanternes et on inverse la journée c'est
à dire que 7h30 9h30 on voit le lever du
soleil cette fois est pas le coucher du
soleil avec toute la féerie et la magie
qu'on peut trouver le matin avec de la
bombe et otc magnifique également c'est
une autre expérience et est ce que on
peut faire quand même le parcours le
soir alors le parcours reste ouvert à
partir de 13 heures nous ouvrons le surf
harry puisque safaris en voiture
lui-même est ouvert et la partir de 14
heures les jardins du château et la
promenade ferrique est ouverte également
et voulait attendre la nuit qui tombe
jusqu'à 18 heures nous sommes ouverts
jusqu'à 18 heures alors les veilles donc
des jardins de thoiry c'est ce week-end
c'était aussi le week-end dernier
est ce que vous allez poursuivre
l'expérience ah si on aimerait bien voir
la réponse nous nous sommes partis pour
l'un pour la poursuivre maintenant nous
entendu enlève du gouvernement qu on
savoir si oui ou non nous allons pouvoir
continuer à notre activité avec toutes
les règles sanitaires possibles pour
pouvoir garantir la sécurité aussi bien
nos collaborateurs que de nos clients et
surtout le cas de nos deux nuls et donc
depuis le début de la crise sanitaire
vous êtes obligé de vous adapter
comment vous avez fait ça doit être
compliqué quand même il faut être
missionné de tous âges il
j'ai la chance d'avoir une équipe qui
est très très flexible et qui s'adapte
qui est passionné de son métier et du
parc donc sur l'ensemble de nos pas
parce que nous avons également deux
autres parcs en france à un portugal et
bien on a fait preuve d'agilité et
surtout on a essayé de garder le contact
a gardé le contact aussi bien dans les
équipes entre les équipes qui sont plus
liés à la clientèle et les équipes qui
sont de toute façon sur le terrain
puisque l'on a sur tous les jours que
coville ou paco vide confinement pas
confinement client à client nos animaux
sont là et on en prend soin tous les
jours toutes les équipes c'est à peu
près une trentaine de personnes tous les
jours un qui travaille qui continuent à
prendre soin des animaux et du cheptel
et puis on a été à gibles dans la
communication on sait dire qu'on a créés
et laisser entrer notre parc au
printemps principalement dans les vingt
jours dans l'est dans le salon de nos
clients avec en installant des petits
comme des petites séquences sur
instagram sur facebook et autres de
façon à raconter notre histoire est
racontée un petit peu ce qui se passait
aux oraux et comment allaient les
animaux
les animaux ont besoin aussi de voir du
monde et de ce contact de façon à garder
le moral
et justement pourquoi pourquoi le zoo
lui est fermé écouter les règles
sanitaires sont strictes tout ce qui est
parc animalier a bien été annoncé fermer
parce que effectivement il peut y avoir
quelques un endroit plus clos un des
tunnels et genre de choses donc voilà
l'état l'état aujourd'hui nous
recommande de fermer notre parc
animalier et toute la flandre le
parcours lui qui se fait par contre
complètement en plein air a eu
l'autorisation d'ouvrir avec un
protocole sanitaire et un sondage
relation très strictes et est ce que
vous avez peut-être très vieux de
nouvelles activités à faire aux zoos
prochainement alors cocher le nom
si tout va bien si pas de tempêtes de
neige aux ouragans ou qu'en fait enfin
et puis sortir de cette crise nous
allons relancer des hébergements de
thoiry au printemps avec quelque chose
d'insolite acquis au rallye qui gardera
l'adn de thoiry nous on va offrir un
espace confort et style très très
restreint quand même est vraiment très
confortable offrir l'expérience nocturne
au sein de la réserve des housses ça va
sortir prochainement en terme de c'est
une exclusivité au long un super va
merci beaucoup de nous avoir donné
l'exclusivité que c'était le vernis et
merci d'avoir été notre invité merci à
vous bonne journée
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
finir cette page loisirs je vous propose
trois idées de sorties pour ce week end
avec une balade sur le sentier demain
cours en vallée de chevreuse à dampierre
en yvelines un sentier balisé de 3 km
est accessible à tous cette promenade de
une à deux heures traverse l'un des plus
grands marais du parc naturel régional
de la haute vallée de chevreuse la
culture à saint quentin en yvelines se
fait en ligne sur le site internet des
médiathèques des comptes en ligne pour
les enfants sont proposés tous les
mercredis on peut aussi visionner des
spectacles comme plein feu un spectacle
d'ombrés les médiathèques sont donc
toujours en mode drive et adaptent leurs
horaires avec le couvre-feu et enfin
l'hôtel restaurant case de cazaux d'or
situé à saint germain en laye lanceuse
gazeau de dans un dernier un dîner
pardon confère samedi 30 janvier vous
pourrez donc écouter le groupe jazz
l'eswi blind maïs depuis votre chambre
d'hôtel tout en dînant et le set it we
kend continue avec eléonore pour parler
de l'actualité
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et comme chaque semaine on retrouve un
journaliste de la rédaction de tv 78 qui
va nous présenter ce qui fera la une la
semaine prochaine cette semaine bixente
mais rien senti stéphane bonsoir bonsoir
alors cette semaine vous allez nous
parler sport et plus particulièrement de
la semaine olympique et paralympique
oui en effet donc elle se déroule du 1er
au 6 février l'un des atouts du
territoire pour cette semaine en
partenariat avec les géo de paris et
qu'on accueillera plusieurs épreuves
dans les yvelines notamment à saint
quentin en yvelines
on retrouve le golf national la colline
d'elancourt pour le vtt ou encore le
vélodrome nationale donc plusieurs
classes de primaires collèges et lycées
auront l'occasion de s'y rendre pour
découvrir ses différents sites
l'objectif en plus de la découverte des
sports et de sensibiliser les plus
jeunes aux valeurs olympiques et
paralympiques et quels sont ces valeurs
bixente alors il y a trois valeurs
principales 1 chacune il ya un symbole
d'abord quand on parle de sport on parle
des forts la devise olympique en latin
ces sites us altius fortius donc plus
vite plus haut plus fort hein c'est ça
si je me trompe pas c'est la devise de
pierre de coubertin oui exactement et
l'honneur donc ça c'est pour prenez le
dépassement de soi ensuite on retrouve
la célèbre flamme olympique que l'on se
passe de pays en pays symbole de
l'amitié entre les peuples et enfin les
anneaux unis l'un à l'autre qui
représente le respect et y at il
d'autres objectifs pour cette semaine où
il y en a plusieurs que contribuer à
changer le regard sur le handicap ou
encore éveillés les jeunes à
l'engagement citoyen tout ça par le
prisme du sport tout un programme merci
bixente mairie un artiste est bonne pour
toutes ces précisions
et pour refermer ce 7,8 week-end en
partenariat avec les surligneurs votre
nouveau rendez vous ce collectif donc
qui décrypte les déclarations des
personnalités publiques et politiques
aujourd'hui retour sur les propos de
nicolas dupont aignan est sûre
l'hydrochlorothiazide moins controversée
contre le coc u19 du professeur didier
raoult est en écoute vincent couronne
docteur en droit à l'université
versailles saint quentin et fondateur
des surligneurs
pour
et
nicolas dupont aignan s'insurge contre
le gouvernement qui selon lui refuse
toute étude impartiale sur l'efficacité
de l'hydroxyde chloroquine cette
molécule longtemps défendue par le
contester professeur out mais qui
pourtant bénéficient de nombreux
soutiens politiques donc notamment le
leader du parti souverainiste debout la
france
or quel est le problème ici est bien
c'est que le gouvernement contrairement
à ce que dit nicolas dupont aignan ce
n'est pas son rôle
alors du coup un débat sur l'hydrologie
chloroquine comment ça marche
comme pour tout débat dans le domaine de
la médecine c'est le code de déontologie
médicale qui dicte la conduite à suivre
cette bible du médecin nous dit que les
stratégies thérapeutiques repose sur des
données acquises par la science et ses
données eh bien elles sont acquises dès
lors qu'elles reflètent un consensus
médical
le problème c'est que parvenir un
consensus médical
c'est un processus très long et qui
habituellement ne se déroule pas sur la
place publique
cela se fait à coups d'études ou
d'articles publiés dans les grandes
revues internationales surtout le même
code de déontologie interdit aux
médecins de jeter sa découverte en
pâture au public avant qu'elle ne soit
est prouvé scientifiquement
pourquoi et bien parce que si un débat
juridique ou climatiques même vif est
inoffensif sur la place publique un
débat médical mal maîtrisée en période
de crise eh bien ça peut pousser le
public à des comportements dangereux
pour sa santé
c'est pourquoi si le gouvernement peut
financer des études ce qui d'ailleurs il
fait déjà
il n'a pas à privilégier une piste
niçoise ni à choisir parmi les
scientifiques ce qui serait supposément
les plus compétents nicolas dupont
aignan est donc hors sujet il y aurait
de quoi s'inquiéter d'ailleurs de sa
vision de la science une science
officielle au service du pouvoir et non
plus indépendante
[Musique]
c'est la fin de votre 7,8 week-end merci
de l'avoir suivi l'information revient
lundi à 18h dans le 7-8 journal présenté
par grégory canale et d'ici là je
souhaite une très bonne soirée et un
très bon week end